republicans gearing up for night three
of the rnc the party looking to counter
democrats attacks
and continue to make the case why
president trump deserves four more years
in the white house
speakers last night highlighting
president trump's accomplishments
defending his actions take a look
over and over issue after issue the
economy the wall the military trade
deals tax cuts
supreme court justices promises made
and promises for the first time were
kept i urge you to make judgment
based on results and not rhetoric our
economic choice
is very clear do you want economic
health
prosperity opportunity and optimism
or do you want to turn back to the dark
days of stagnation recession
and pessimism despite the unprecedented
attacks from the media and opposition
he will not give up in fact if you tell
him he cannot be done
he just works harder first lady in the
rose garden there
okay greg your big moment last night
oh it had to be the naturalization
ceremony it always brings a lump to your
throat even though the media will mock
it because
they always wonder how silly it is to
want to come to america which as you've
heard already
is a racist sexist imperialistic hell
except that maybe four billion people
want to get into it
it was also great in that ceremony to
see non-celebrities
who can't wait to come to america as
opposed to celebrities who always keep
vowing to leave america but never do
and it's easy when you're rich right
when you've already made it when you're
a professional athlete
to preach defeatism to others i have
here's an observation if you took a venn
diagram of people who became naturalized
citizens right
put that in one circle and then you put
the other circle
rioters those circles will never
overlap you'd have a better chance of
finding brian stelter on a peloton
than a naturalized citizen rioting
okay uh juan up and coming star kentucky
attorney general daniel cameron take a
listen to this
i think often about my ancestors who
struggled for freedom
and as i think of those giants and their
broad shoulders
i also think about joe biden who says if
you aren't voting for me
you ain't black mr vice president look
at me
i am black we are not all the same sir
i am not in chains my mind is my own
and you can't tell me how to vote
because of the color of my skin
we have not seen the end of the kentucky
attorney general no i think i think he's
got a political future
he's quite a good speaker and one of my
friends said he was very good-looking
juan i told you that in confidence no no
no
actually it was someone else on this
panel but i won't say who i'll leave
that up to her
so i if you had asked me to pick a star
last night brett i would have said
melania trump
uh you know that whole setting uh in the
rose garden was
phenomenal just spectacular obviously
there are questions about the ethics of
it like but
let's forget that for the moment and i
thought she did a good job uh
why because i thought that unlike the
rest of the convention
her speech was an outlier in that she
spoke emphatically
and empathetically about the coronavirus
and said that you know she understands
people who are suffering and she's
particularly related
and of course this is the target
audience for the entire convention
to moms to suburban moms and said the
president
is fighting for you you are warriors and
the president is
in your fight the problem is the same
day larry kudlow the economic advisor
is talking about the coronavirus as if
it's in the past tense as if it's
already gone
and then you have a problem where today
it's reported that the president
is pressing the cdc to change
change its standards for testing so not
to test people who've been exposed again
the idea is fewer tests
therefore will have less data to
indicate the severity of the coronavirus
problem so many months after it started
danny you heard juan reference it there
there's a big dust up
some of the media and definitely
democrats saying that the trappings of
the white house and
and all of this are wrong some saying
illegal
uh the white house chief of staff mark
meadows saying today outside the beltway
people don't care you buy that well a
couple things so i do think that the
rant they ran this through the council's
office
and actually the rose garden is exempt
so let's just cross that one off the
list and besides
the trump family and the entire rnc they
were planning to be
in charlotte north carolina this week
they wouldn't even be at the white house
if it weren't for the pandemic and joe
biden wouldn't be in delaware if it
weren't for the pandemic everybody would
be traveling
everywhere so i think that the hatch act
violations is such a small ball issue
because truly is anyone did anyone wake
up today wishing that those
new americans were not citizens today or
did anybody wake up thinking gosh
john pounder ponder really didn't
deserve that
pardon last night from the white house
you should have had it from somewhere
else i don't think so
those were big moments and here's
something that jim garrity at national
review said that the unconventional
convention is kind of a blessing in
disguise because it forced the
president's team
to have him doing things rather than
just saying things
and if i had to pick a star last night
i'm going with the maine lobsterman
he said that in 2016 he did not vote for
president trump he did not think he
would follow through on conservative
principles
his mind has been changed and so he is
going to vote for him but importantly it
was a policy issue
there was the eu tariffs on lobster the
president worked that issue with senator
collins of maine
they got that resolved and now you think
he is saying that
that industry is preserved and saved
under the president so you're looking at
specific
concrete things that's what i would say
if you are
an independent voter or a crossover
voter you're not exactly sure something
like that
might change your mind lobster the
accent alone
jesse wrap it up i would say that last
night showed that america first
puts people first you're talking about
lobstermen steelworkers dairy farmers
who
under barack obama and joe biden
suffered and under this president
have succeeded so that really puts a
face to the trade policies
tax and regulation cuts there was a
strong outreach to christians
from the right to try children
whose lives were saved to the story from
the pro-life woman about a
baby fighting off an abortion in the
womb
while the planned parenthood
administrator cracked jokes
they talked about how this president the
first president in decades who hasn't
initiated a new war
in a term compare that to joe biden who
was backing wars in
serbia and syria and iraq and libya
like i think it was dana's boyfriend the
kentucky
a.g really didn't even think about that
i know it was you dana
said that joe biden's a backwards
thinker on race
and said that he's made more promises to
illegals than he has to americans
and then pam bond he really did a number
on joe's
grifting family there was also talk
about the one war the president has
waged which was opioids 33 years
old deaths from overdoses have been on
the rise
first year ever they've now declined so
i think what the president did was
he really said these are my policies
these are the people
that are benefiting from my policies joe
biden won't tell you his policies
because they're too crazy
and his policies hurt people and i hate
to say this i agree with juan
melania was the star last night you
could hear a pin drop in the rose garden
how often does that happen here on the
five yeah